DUCKS IN T TERY NEARLY
KNOCKED IT BACK INTO HIS
FINALLY THE SHARKS CLEAR THEE SE
PLAYER MISHANDLES THAT PUCK AT .
HE FEEL RIGHT OVER THE BACK SIDE
LITTLE DROP PASS PICKED UP BY N.
SHARKS-DUCKS QUICK TO MOVE IT
CHANGE
SIDE, SAWCHENKO GOT THE BLOCKER
ON THAT.
>> IT WAS TWO ON ONE BREAK THIS
TIME FOROR THAT WAY
ACROSS AGET CALLED FOR THE SECOD
PENALTY.
>> THAT'S HIS PLACE.
SHARKS WIN THE DRAW, MIDDLETON
TO THE CORNER TRYING TO DIRECTLF
HIM.
THE REBOUND DOESN'T GO OFF TO
THE SIDE SO THE SHOTN MISSES
LINDHOLM WITH A PASS THAT WILL
COME ALL THE THE GOALTENDER. ANR
TEAM'SFF
THE FACE-OFF DWAW.
HE
HAND AND THE UP THE BOARD HE'S
GOT IT ASPENALTY FOR THE THE
SHOT NOW STEPS CLOSER, POPS IT
INTO THE
UP THE BOARDS, RAKELL GOT A
PIECE OF
HE SETS THE SCREEN AND CREATES E
AND HAMPUS LINDHOLM
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE, DOES
NICK BE19 O GOT THE
HERE, JOHN.
>> W W
LOOK. IF IT WAS BEN AT 2 JUST 4
MINUTES LEFT AT HONDA CLEAR.
POSITION.
>> SHURNLG BENINO LOOKED FACE-ON
THIS GAME.